boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don Satya
we are still on site at Indy BIOS demo
day number 8 we are now going to be
talking with Michelle Xue hello hi there
thank you so much for coming on really
appreciate it no problem really excited
she's a CEO of tutorial
alright so teach us about what you were
just pitching on stage yeah so here at
centaurian we are making more
sustainable indigo dye for the denim
industry so in a nutshell we basically
have created a completely nature based
process to combat the what we like to
call two-part problem with indigo so
problem number one if I can get into it
already if you don't mind there's a
chemical synthesis process indigo is
heavily petroleum reliant and so to make
it you have to require it requires over
a hundred kilograms of indigo for every
kilogram sorry 100 kilograms of
petroleum for every kilogram of indigo
produced but on top of that that
chemical synthesis process also involves
other toxic chemicals like formaldehyde
and cyanide like literally known poisons
going into the production of this core
ingredient for making your jeans so
that's one problem and then the second
problem is indigo is kind of a unique
dye so it crystallizes really quickly in
the presence of air and that makes it
not water-soluble and so to actually
apply it as a dye you have to add in
equal parts a water polluting chemical
reducing agent and that stuff ends up in
you know the waste streams polluting
water sources all over Asia and it's
really bad for the environment so our
solution basically addresses you're
about to get into solution there's so
much to saw and pack with we're wearing
jeans right now and like I we don't know
about these things I don't know about
these things not really we kind of dig
into the supply chain of things whoa
okay so how is it a hundred kilograms of
patron for a kilogram of indigo yeah
what it's insane so the key kind of
the key chemical in producing the Indigo
is this petroleum derivative called
aniline and it's kind of an inefficient
process right so you need a lot of
petroleum in order to make this aniline
compound and in fact it's you know the
petroleum reliance right like
non-renewable sources that's part of it
and then also this aniline compound is
known to be potentially carcinogenic so
it's just like all sorts of problems
that goes into the this chemical
production process and then the what are
we so what are we doing with this indigo
so we get a kilogram this indigo and
then there's some the work so we're
polluting water systems as well because
we can't how do because we have to get
it on the actual gene material are these
like how do we dye the fabric is the
fabric just like not dyed indigo when we
I mean it certainly is so actually I
guess when you make your jeans let's
let's let's take a look deeper dive into
the supply chain right so you don't you
don't just you know put the dye in a
bucket and then like take the full
garment and just kind of like dip it in
and get tie-dye not not at all but I
think what actually makes denim such a
pro looting and potentially problematic
kind of area of fashion is the fact that
its supply chain is so complex so you
need to take these cotton threads in the
thread form and dye it at that form in
order to form this kind of like ring dye
effect and then you weave these you know
indigo dyed threads together in order to
form the fabric and then after you form
the fabric you can kind of like wash
down the fabric in order to create kind
of the faded effect and because it has
that kind of white core you can fade it
down and then it'll create the lighter
blues you know kind of it brings out the
white you know colors in the inside of
the threads so that's that's kind of
taking you through how it happens but of
course because you're kind of going
through that complex production line now
you have a lot of indigo that's wasted
you have a lot of kind of the runoff
from the you know both the water
pollution in the
the dye process as well as sort of the
washing process afterwards and where are
we making most of the blue jeans in the
world right now
most of it is made in Asia I yeah most
of it is made in Asia there's actually
no more dye mills here in the United
States yeah yeah then it's it's pretty
rough I think a more interesting
question actually is what are we making
most of the indigo okay well where's and
that is primarily in China so over 90%
of the world's indigo supply is made in
China and over 50% is made by just one
producer alone so it's a really
consolidated market it's all gobbly one
is 50% yes exactly exactly and so of
course they can go you know very much
like a not environmentally regulated
right and you know and then if it is
it's called wonderful chemicals yeah
yeah of course is called ironically it's
called Wow
that's like the Happy Meal this is a
ridiculous to get away with this kind of
stuff all right okay continue yes no I
mean I yeah only other thing to add is
just it's like even China right it's
like cracking down an environmental
regulation and so then the convenient
move is like push over the border to
Mongolia to make the proposal yeah well
some wonderful chemicals just like
moving countries and the regulations kid
damn is crazy okay so this is what's
wrong
all right so what is what are you doing
that is right and sustainable and the
future of yeah yeah so our process like
I said is is nature inspired so we
basically mimic a process that happens
in plants we are using bacteria so
completely sustainable sources and
completely renewable sources
having bacteria feeding them with sugar
and literally having those bacteria grow
and secrete an indigo precursor and then
we apply this enzymatic treatment that
then also bypasses the need for the
reducing agent and that's how we kind of
apply our diet yeah
so little sim its oh whoa yeah it's a
little simplistic it's just complex
biology so so okay so back so bacteria
seem like they're like so many people
have now sat down here and just been
like yeah we you know add genes to
bacteria and make them produce different
things and I'm just like wow
bacteria good this is like these are
billions of years old and like you know
humans are just like millions of years
old it's just so interesting thinking
about like what aspects of evolution we
have yet to understand can help us live
a more sustainable future especially
connect here and stuff all right so
let's break this down so what specific
bacteria is it and whenever you can
share with us yeah sure well it's ecoli
it's very common ministry in fact okay
and then what do you at this is this in
a bioreactor where where are you doing
this okay yep so yeah we grow it in you
know any sort of like range of scale of
bioreactor so in the last four months at
a new bio we've actually we started at
like a 10 liter which is about the
equivalent of a large lab scale
bioreactor size and we actually ran our
solution through a 300 liter bioreactor
size and so really scaled up our process
in order to actually make the dye
threads and actually test our technology
on an on a real industrial machine yeah
okay and then what's going on in the bio
reactors with the e.coli bacteria so
what are you at like tell us about this
process yeah well we actually even have
a time-lapse that you can see on our
Instagram page of kind of the whole
thing being performed but perfect all in
bed that right here are people to watch
right now no totally so you know you can
basically watch it happen the the you
know bacteria they grow right and then
they as they grow they just secrete this
indigo precursor actually some you know
normal indigo also comes out and then
you can kind of see the blue color form
before your eyes and how do you find
that this specific e.coli can secrete
indigo precursors yeah yeah I mean I
think that was based on a lot of the
existing literature so I will say here
I'm not the the scientists the brilliant
scientific mind behind this I'm actually
the the business that I speak so well
about it
yes please thank you my co-founder Tammy
is actually the the one who invented it
so she did well she found the specific
enzyme in the indigo plant that is
actually the kind of like for the key
sort of core of our technological
innovation there's an enzyme in the
indigo plant and then that is how does
that enzyme get used in the bioreactor
with e.coli mhm
so we basically combine the enzyme into
we or we bring the enzyme into the
e.coli and then that allows the bacteria
to actually create the blue color whoa
okay and then what is the process like
with is the secreting an indigo
precursor and then what do you do you
just like take that from the bioreactor
and then yeah tell us about that process
yeah so we if we take it there there's
actually a good amount of purification
work and concentration work that needs
to be done in order to actually apply
that sort of product as a dye I will say
I we that that's one of the key areas
that we still want to do a little bit
more of right so when you get it out of
the bioreactor it's you know you have
the the precursor but you also have some
media in the you know in the in the
broth and so it's funny we we didn't do
a whole lot of purification that's
actually a major milestone of kind of
like a work stream of work that we plan
to do in the next couple months we
actually made our first hire over yeah
yeah who joined us about a week ago and
he brings industry experience in
downstream processing so he's gonna be
huge for helping us do that but we
didn't do a whole lot of purification
work we instead just like took it
straight to the Machine and you know
applied our enzymatic treatment and then
you know sort of like ran that process
and so what happened was because we had
some media still
in the the genes are our blue jeans our
prototype kind of like the red samples
are actually slightly too green so we
are literally baking genes that are
greener the world they're not actually
super green but you know there's like a
slight tinge for anybody who's like
super familiar with the denim industry
but that's why the downstream processing
is going to be a major kind of work
stream for us okay there's a broth that
comes out then you have to purify the
broth for just indigo exactly then you
can take that and then how does then
that get applied to yeah yeah yeah so
actually so when we purify it out we
would purify our indigo precursor okay
and then that's what we would combine
with our enzyme which would basically
form this solution for dyeing which is
called leuco indigo and so that's what
you kind of put into the machine and
then as the machine runs the Indigo kind
of forms onto the dye oh okay okay and
then then it's the similar process of
the thread that I mean you thread
together and then that's how you make
the actual exactly exactly so yeah what
comes out of that process would be all
of the blue threads that you would need
to make a denim fabric now I should also
say that one of the one of the
interesting things about the denim
production too is that you know you need
blue threads but you also need white
threads and you kind of crosshatch that
together and that's why when you yeah
when you like cut into your jeans for
example some of the threads are white
that are showing yeah yeah and that's
kind of otherwise it'd be that just
solid exam you can see the white other
colors in here right while just
awareness level about yeah understanding
jeans in general is really important
when you're you know at the store really
think in the supply chain about where
the materials are sourced from how
they're actually made all this type of
stuff and then how about are you looking
to just sell indigo is your thing or are
you looking to literally make like a
gene product line that's a great
question
so our business model is actually going
to be in phases so
one of the key things that we are you
know sure of right now is consumers
don't know a lot about this and you know
we can't we can't just rely on brands to
tell the story right we have to also be
able to tell the story ourselves and
really start to raise that awareness and
build the consumer demand so to do that
we're gonna start actually by launching
our own very limited line of jeans and
that's going to kind of get the
conversation going about sustainable
denim right might be star patrasche
right 200 pairs that's all you get per
city good luck yeah yeah people like I
got them look at my Instagram actually
you can have the you know exclusive
edition of sanctorium jeans I'm a
sustainable person I support sustainable
cool these marketing strategies okay
cool so that's gonna be perfect but then
of course right now you know we've
already gotten really overwhelming
response from the denim industry I think
brands are already pretty eager to
partner with us so then our next move
would be co-branding lines with jeans
you know with existing denim
manufacturers starting in kind of the
premium segment where you know we can
really start to incorporate that
technology and start to tell that story
but of course in the long term our
vision is yeah we want our technology in
this way of you know making and applying
denim indigo dye so for every single
pair of jeans out there so you're gonna
obsolete wonderful chemicals out of
there absolutely if they can get 50%
market share we can get running through
new future it's we we have to start
paying attention to these sorts of
environmental concerns now we have to do
things differently so we we think that
you know there's this future where that
kind of you know wasteful toxic
production it just doesn't have to be
allowed anymore whoa I wonder example
the similar concept more and more young
people being born into the world they're
become more and more aware of the supply
chain processes about how to make things
more sustainable and then
just unleashing more biotech that we
still don't have an really picked an
uncovered like this indigo enzyme added
to a coli and like what you know and so
do you think like cost-wise are we
talking like right now it might be you
know pretty expensive compared to what
you know wonderful chemicals are doing
but yeah down the line like in terms of
just price over time you're you're
thinking like obviously you don't need a
hundred kilograms of petroleum yeah yeah
so these are the this because that costs
a lot of money to like extract that and
yeah sure I mean the chemical process is
cheap that's the only way they're able
to do what they're you know currently
doing and such at such large scales
right um yeah I mean I think I what I
would say is the dye you know process or
at least just sort of the dyeing
component in terms of the cogs of making
a pair of jeans it's actually you know
really small and so there's a good
amount of we think sensitivity you know
or D sensitivity into you know in terms
of your willingness to to pay more for
some more sustainable ingredients right
and when you're talking about like the
core ingredient most visible ingredient
in your genes if we scaled up our
process right now we would actually we
could actually be making our our indigo
dye for three dollars more per pair of
jeans that's it and so it's like you
know yeah sure current you know indigo
production process is probably something
like a couple cents per pair of jeans
and that's what we would aim for more in
the long term but I think the point
we're trying to make here is that right
in consumers eyes if we're really
exactly you were really to see
especially if you're talking about fifty
dollar pairs of jeans two hundred dollar
pairs of jeans right like who wouldn't
want to pay a couple of dollars more for
a better made pair of change so we're
sensitive to the ecological factor and I
think we're yeah I think we need D
sensitive to the three dollar price
increase if the price of jeans was
already like a fifty or a hundred
dollars whatever okay okay yeah and the
second phase to I see the partnerships
and stuff this is a cool stuff and then
we're okay so where are you so you just
did first higher so what else do you are
you looking for right now your
around leaving in the bio as well so
what's the round what are you looking to
do with it yeah yeah so we're raising a
two and a half million dollar or Seagram
we are primarily that's gonna get us
about a year and a half or two years of
runway in order to launch our first line
of jeans that's kind of the big goal to
do that we're gonna need some strain
engineering purification work of course
like I you know talked about I think the
strain engineering work is gonna be very
much ongoing the purification work is
going to be sort of like a you know deep
dive first development so that we can
then at first priority so that we can
then prototype a lot of different fabric
concepts with shades that are you know
established and standard in the indigo
and denim industry and then you know
scale up to ten thousand liters with
that process so that we can then release
our first line of jeans nice okay yeah
you have the roadmap down I love it I
love it that's what that's well that's
all we need it I love it okay cool I
think we did a yeah I think we did a
good job covering like centaurum good
job like there's a lot of good stuff
that you guys are doing I'm very proud
of you thanks for coming on the show
thank you so much thank you huge shout
out to all you guys for tuning in we
greatly appreciated love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below in the
episode also do check out the links
below to tinctoria check out the links
below to indie bio as well support the
artists entrepreneurs the organizations
around the world that you believe in
support simulation so you keep doing
cool things like coming on site to indie
bio for interviews and also share more
content like this with your friends your
family coworkers people online on social
media talk more about these things the
supply chains around all the products
that we buy every single day really
think about it deeply and inspire
children to think about it deeply and
change the systems through a grit better
ecological future go and build the
future everyone manifest your dreams
into well we love you very much we'll
see you soon